have you watched the new season of
stranger things no
nah
i haven't watched
any of it i don't think i watched the
first season maybe but
it's too late now for me i just you know
too big
this season
despite the corniness
actually it pulled me in right at the
end really
it's the last season right yeah
but this it's like it's like what they
did with ozark and it's like two parts
oh okay so there's the season five
gotcha
netflix is just trying to prolong their
death yeah yeah
did you see there's this new
show i don't know someone dm'd it to me
because like all i do now is review bad
shows the sopranos what
no
you say the sopranos is bad no no i was
joking don't even joke about that i was
joking about some gen z kid being like
yo you should check out this old
sopranos this is all [ __ ] up hbo like
reality
something it's like about the mafia yeah
it's called the sopranos that's so funny
yeah i made a reference to seinfeld this
weekend and then i felt like portions of
the crowd just like
like i hit the back of their brain
it was like i went through all their
knowledge like um yeah we have no record
of that reference
what is seinfeld
yeah anyway
uh this was the show you were describing
seinfeld
no
sign felt like putting this dick in your
mouth
see i fell put like putting this dick in
your mouth see how i feel yeah okay
um no it's i think it's they said it was
a show where they take like entitled
just
yeah they take like entitled millennials
or gen z's or something and they drop
them in the wilderness oh is this the
millennial mountain thing
maybe
peop remember we talked about this on
the podcast and i we were like talking
about ideas
just that we had and i and i
talked about the one where i was saying
it'd be really
interesting to like take influencers
out into like a cabin yeah yeah
so it's the same [ __ ] yeah so maybe it
is can you look that up actually yeah
out in the wild and they all think that
they're like going on like a love island
like just like an actually yeah yeah
like they're at the villa yeah we
brainstormed the exact same exact idea
yeah literally the exact same setup
that's crazy uh i mean it's not that
crazy of an idea what if we took seven
dumb people who are rich and we
pretended that they were gonna go to an
island but secretly
they have to [ __ ] in a bush yeah oh no
have you ever seen a loan
yeah that [ __ ] show yeah is so good
it's also really funny that how terrible
those guys are at um cinematography
well because they film themselves no but
it's really funny how like it's they're
not they get to the thing and they're
like
apparently there's uh there's and then
they have to walk into this pelican case
yeah yeah and they have to like it's
like all right so i gotta like put the
receiver on and
they're just holding this gigantic
like camcorder like all right so i think
it's so cool no it is but it just makes
it so genuine yeah
i do think it's really funny that
they're out there camping but then there
is this like
studio grade pelican case with like
batteries and instructions and like i
know you're doing the survival thing but
also please set up this very expensive
broadcast camera and make sure you
capture everything and i want to explain
the show for people that don't know and
are listening like what what the [ __ ]
you mean so like
they basically find
10 survivalists or 12 or something i
don't know the number but they take a
bunch of survivalists which are people
that go out into the woods and just live
off the land basically yep with nothing
and so these people
compete against each other they drop
them in like a random remote location
and all separately so they're all
completely alone
and
they're they're like trained for two
weeks before they leave on how to use
all the camera gear so that yeah each
one of them gets a pelican filled with
like camera gear and mics and whatever
and they have to film themselves the
whole time and the whole point is just
to survive
as long as they can but they don't know
like how the other people are doing it
yeah so they don't know how many are
left yeah
so the last person standing wins
basically so super intense they're like
killing alligators and beavers and yeah
like one of them killed a on one season
i guess he like killed a bear i think or
a moose or something like that and dried
all the meat and let he lasted for like
a month just
just off the meat that's crazy
sauce is [ __ ]
yeah does folate moose meat
okay
kind of gay
no it is pretty crazy i'm gonna make the
modern version of a loan where i'm gonna
find 10 people in a discord server
and um
because they're already alone and then
i'm going to uh take away their doordash
app
and for 30 days they have to actually
cook their own food
and see if they can survive just
browsing the internet and making their
own meals
yeah no frozen [ __ ] no mac and cheese
yeah nah they have to cook their own all
of it yeah yeah and then uh it's [ __ ]
onions
cutting this [ __ ] has made me so goddamn
sad that's so hard yeah
it's so hard what's happening
you know how i'm alone though sometimes
when they hang the meat out
[Music]
uh
you know like an animal will like try to
come and eat it
the on the discord version of alone
because there'll be 10 dumers in 10
different cities they're we'll put them
all with roommates and occasionally they
just have a hungry roommate
who like shows up and knows how to cook
and that guy will wake up and be like
damn we got steak yeah and he'll start
cooking the steak and they have to
figure out how to get the roommate off
of cooking the steak like they have to
use their social skills to be like
hey
no
that's my state
could leave my state yeah but you
weren't like were you using it you don't
cook right
i i do now i do yeah no you don't
[Laughter]
i'm making this [ __ ]
like it is mine
it is mine now starting now
the moment it went into this pan it is
mine
just some gym guy yeah
nah nah this isn't yours yeah nah
you don't eat steak man stand up to him
stand up to him
that's mine as he's holding the [ __ ]
camera in front of us
that's my stake
it's mine what are you doing you
vlogging
dude you don't vlog you don't vlog bro
you don't talk here turn the camera
around on me yeah
that's better watch me watch me cook
this steak
get in the mouth hitting the macros
right now
yeah i'm mid-cut
i'm looking leaner right
i'm looking leaner def want to document
this cut dude i'm gonna look be looking
sick in two weeks the producers of the
show are like what the [ __ ] is this
footage dude
it's kind of good honestly
who's this guy very charismatic
you should film him less it's making you
look bad
so this is called snowflake flake
mountain yeah that's the name of it i'll
go i'll actually watch this
it's like yeah
we don't need this it's like alone it
actually is kind of funny the concept of
the ex like doing the exact same show is
alone yeah but the people aren't
experienced and surviving yeah
you just drop these people down and
they're like does anyone have a charger
[ __ ]
we do have solar power here
okay this is just you know
retreat
for um like a technology retreat is this
new
yeah
i think it just came out just came out
someone messaged me about the show and
they were like dude this is like exactly
what
you guys were describing on the podcast
like like two years ago they're like
they're like it feels like it's verbatim
yeah netflix is scraping the bottom of
the barrel for ideas they're going back
and watching our archives yeah they're
definitely yeah watching us and being
like these are good ideas yeah
definitely
you